welcome to another ideas that matter
conversation this is actually a
conversation I've been wanting to have
for a long time my guest today is Nancy
Sherman somebody who I've had the
opportunity to chat with and interact
with and ask some of the questions that
I'm going to be bringing up about let's
call it recent history of ideas and if
you don't know Nancy Sherman's work you
really ought to
her most recent work has been on
stoicism in particular stoic wisdom
ancient lessons for modern resilience
which came out two years ago
um stoic Warriors the ancient
philosopher well ancient philosophy
behind the military mine in 2005 she
also has a book on
um called after War healing the Moral
Moral wounds of our soldiers and we'll
probably talk about moral injury and
topics like that but the reason I wanted
to to bring her here is actually to talk
about something that goes way way back
to a much earlier book that I myself
have greatly benefited from the uh the
fabric of character Aristotle's theory
of virtue so um well I should say too so
you know uh Nancy Sherman is is a
distinguished University Professor uh at
Georgetown
um you you know you've probably seen her
work in bookstores and and heard her if
you're hip to this sort of thing on
podcasts and other interviews she's
actually been the
um what do we call it the plenary
speaker so like the distinguished guest
yeah the keynote or something like you
know there we go yeah so uh anything
else you want to say about yourself
before we jump in Nancy no but just
thank you so much Greg for uh having me
and um happy to chat about
um I tried to pull out the book so I
could kind of remember but yeah behind
you a little yeah so he remember what
was what was going on yeah well let's
let's talk uh Aristotle and not just
Aristotle himself but let's say like the
last 50 years of Aristotle scholarship
so as I mentioned you know um the fabric
of character really important work for
me but it's it's within let's say a
genre of work on Aristotle that was
attentive to aspects of his work that I
think were being sidelined in a lot of
respects and so just a little bit of my
own background I don't want to indulge
in this too much but when I was a
graduate student I was really getting
into Aristotle and seeing the potential
of his work for me it was kind of a
no-brainer just reading through them
that that the intellectual or cognitive
side and the affective side
were you know uh you know Aristotle
poses them as one is above the other but
they're really interfused with each
other and so much of the literature
didn't really recognize that even with
um you know fortinbau's work on emotions
much much earlier on
um and then I I encountered your work
and I encountered Gisela Striker and and
a number of other people as well who
were saying oh no no this this is this
is Aristotle this really is something
that's there and it was it was important
for me because I could be like well I'll
say I'm not crazy
um I you know other import people who
are much
you know much further along in their
careers who've done much more research
who spent much more time on it they also
are doing this and I can take their
articles or take their books and draw
upon that and the thing that struck me
after a while and it did strike me right
away is that most of the scholarship in
this this vein of Aristotle scholarship
you know noting the importance of
emotions and particularity it was being
done by women
and I thought to myself well I mean this
can't be a coincidence
um you know and and at the time ethics
of care was also very big and and so
there was this attentiveness to like you
know I I'm gonna be facetious here you
know Men Are from Mars Women Are from
Venus so men are Justice oriented and
women are care oriented and I I think
that that's a complete caricature but I
think that like in Aristotle
scholarship particularly in ethics you
know
um it played a major role so this is
something I've always wanted to ask you
about as somebody who is kind of at the
center of that very movement and I'm you
know sure has a lot of insight about it
so with that Preamble uh what can you
tell us
that's a great Preamble
um there were a lot of confluences at
the time that were
uh really you know subconscious in a way
you know maybe they were in the air but
they were definitely subconscious so I
was at Harvard and my advisor was Martha
nesbaum
um and I did spend a year better part of
a year not a whole year in England
during my Harvard years of second year
we could go abroad and I was in London
and also Cambridge Cambridge University
so at King's College so
uh and I had a letter of Entry you might
say to Miles Burnett okay yeah I was
said you could
you could go and study with him and that
would be a good way to spend the
semester you would get credit or
something like that and also Richard
sarabji um they were okay they were in
London at the time and co-teaching of
course actually
um
now
early on I got interested in uh
moral education character
um
habituation never appealed to me because
that doesn't really characterize what
was going on it's a bad translation for
a fismus or paigea but it's you know it
was sort of cultivation character
cultivation anyway we might say how you
become good
um and
miles had written a great um influential
article at the time on Aristotle
learning to be good or something right
correct and sarabji had also written one
on roles of intellect and moral
habituation which is about practical
wisdom
Martha had just recently published on
the motion of animals so she was very
much into
intentionality and Wiggins David Wiggins
kind of stuff
um
and but I wasn't that interested in I
was much more interested in the what we
now know as moral psychology but at that
time we did not call it moral psychology
I don't know what we called it I just
you know my dissertation was aerosol's
theory of moral habituation but you know
I don't really know
and I
Rousseau
Village he was my second advisor as it
came to be and
I
devoured part three of the theory of
Justice I simply devoured it you know I
thought he gave short shrift to a lot of
stuff but you know it was interesting
and
uh at Harvard at the time also of course
there was Carol Gilligan once I got back
right right and I had lunch with her a
number of times and she was fighting the
war you you say about
um the care it became the care ethic but
that wasn't what she called it and
thinking about Larry kohlberg her own
advisor Lawrence kohlberg
and his more Justice oriented as you
said approach so that was kind of in the
background you might say
I wouldn't say it was
ever very well defined it was of course
I'll just be honest it was the early 70s
mid 70s
I was very active at Harvard at the time
and when women's students Coalition
where we were fighting hard for more
tenure lines for women Derek Bach was
president at the time razovsky was the
uh D I think we called him Dean Dean of
our faculty of Arts and Science anyway
it was a large uh discussion about micro
inequities and how they would show up in
subliminal ways in a oral defense does
your chest have do you have freckles on
your chest like you have them on your
face said to a you know in a science
um oral exam I mean horrible stuff yeah
yeah so it was there was stuff in the
background but it was you know feminism
second wave feminism was strong at the
time
my own interests though kind of
gravitated not only to a bituation but
thinking about two books
of 10 so a fifth of the nick of McKeon
similar numbers in the udemian ethics
lesser red and um and very critical
passages in the Magnum Aurelia and some
stuff in the politics
uh John Cooper had I think just left
Harvard that point was now Pittsburgh I
think and he had written these very too
influential articles at the time they
were two they later became merged as one
on a friendship in Aristotle and
happens I later um
published that in a critical essays on
Aristotle's ethics I brought together
some of that work but so
say all these things were in the Air
Care ethics was not really out there
virtue ethics
exist
or even had heard of it so I wasn't
thinking of repurposing
an ancient text for modern readers I had
no interest in that at all and I didn't
even that wasn't any part of a plan or
project and I don't know of who was
doing that in those days Emily wordy was
also hanging around Cambridge
Massachusetts in those days and very
interested always in emotions and my own
advice I'm called advisor but one of the
person who put me on to Aristotle really
was Arya Cosman
um at Haverford who is known for his
work on metaphysics
um but he wrote a very important article
very early on he himself was a Oh I
think he would well he was a student of
Stanley Campbell but also maybe gel Owen
who was at Harvard when he was there
anyway it was called on being properly
affected a horrible thing yeah
and it was that is a great article
though
citing that quite a bit myself how can
it be that we're held responsible for
our emotions if emotions aren't chosen
that was kind of the worry it um
well that led me down when I once I did
my um uh graduate work and started
writing my dissertation it led me down
many Avenues thinking about well how are
emotions if not voluntary
the choices of some sort or other and
pro-hiretic as Aristotle would say Pro
um deliberatively chosen how could they
be
um how could we be in some ways held
responsible and how could we be moreover
praised and blamed not only for our
actions but also for our emotions
um and so they're both part of our
conduct that bit me as a worry
um I never really talked to Rea he was a
very dear friend until his death a few
years ago
um about that but that article you know
was there it's not a
clumsy article in the way that articles
sometimes were of that era and I
wouldn't say it flows
sometimes when I teach it I regret that
I teach it but um it raised a lot of uh
of questions and it was sort of in the
back of my mind always if we are
response if we're both responsible for
not only our actions but emotions and at
the end of book six
um you know we're sort of led to believe
practical wisdom for nasis and a good
character
are integrated you can't have one
without the other
and even you know and and though all of
book two in the nick of McKeon ethics
sort of is about emotions and not much
discussion I mean poorly discussed there
and pleasures and pains and you only get
to practical wisdom by sort of three or
it's about deliberation and then six and
a very difficult book
I thought well there's got to be more to
it than that that must just be like a
Serial way of addressing it in lectures
so to speak I gotta do it in time so you
got to talk about one and then another
and one another but they're very
integrated so that's sort of what got me
going that I thought it was really odd
and
and not um and you know I was steeped in
cons as well you couldn't have been in
those
breathe that air at that time with John
Rawls as the king of rediscovering and I
would I use that that's a bad phrase but
he discovered after writing a theory of
justice that he really had to go back
and give lectures on the history of
moral philosophy because
that's really what he had been drawing
on when it wasn't economics and Kenneth
Arrow kind of stuff and
um and Kant we all were
um Smitten by lectures he gave every
semester on the history of moral
philosophy and Phil 168 I think it was
called and many semesters it was devoted
to Khan and what he was Finding really
interesting in Khan wasn't just how to
work the categorical imperative
procedure care of um
O'Neill nor Nell O'Neill
his first real con
um student
um before Barbara Hermann even
um was
um
he was thinking about the doctrine of
virtue the metaphysics of morals and all
of the
um you know how you cultivate sympathy
as a as a way of of mobilizing you might
say the
um the um motive of Duty yeah and so
emotions were you know is very
interesting Hume the quiet you know the
calmer passions and that they must be at
work also and and
um in the work of the judicious
spectator and the like and partial
Spectrum so
there was a whole chapter book era Epoch
of of
um moral philosophy that was being on in
many ways we
investigated and part of the oversight
really is a contribution of
anglo-american philosophy you know
Gilbert Ryle had invented sort of
ancient Philosophy for modern times he
was the teacher of g-e-l-o-n
um in Britain uh gelo and then went on
to have his students found Julia Annas
or geezel striker came from the German
side of life but
um
um others um you know I fear uh um John
Cooper was like was a graduate yeah at
Harvard at the time when Owen was there
um Terry Irwin was blastocious student
but the the
the the Prejudice of Britain was of
course that those two books of the
nicomician ethics never existed because
what would what would you
how does that really explain a theory of
action which is sort of part of what was
of interest at the time
you know there was a very important
article by Errol Bedford as well and he
was another one of my Stu teachers from
way back he was an undergraduate tutor I
did a year abroad I have a lot of
written in my background a year abroad
in Edinburgh okay he was one of my and
also Sally Waterloo was Sarah Waterloo
now Sarah Brody but at the time she was
called so oh yeah she was my tutor as
well but she really was only interested
in early on in the metaphysics and in
logic she wasn't really focusing on
Aristotle's ethics but anyway
um Errol Bedford had written a very
early article on emotions
and essentially
um
you know there was so much that it that
there was he was a victim shenan and
there was a lot of conversation about
emotions not just being feels in your
head but
behavioral things that you could kind of
be I don't think he talked about the
morality of it of accountability so
there was some you know beginnings
beginning conversations about that but
it started to really interest pique my
curiosity and that's a long-winded
answer but that's some of the background
okay so that I mean that tells us a lot
about how you sort of moved into that
that field and who was doing things at
the time
um I mean is there anything to this like
notion that
um now you know these these female
Aristotle Scholars were not saying oh
well we're gonna approach this in a
feminist way I mean there are people
doing that later on
um somebody Marsha homie acted a little
about that later yeah I was thinking
like like later on in 2000 there's that
um Barbara koziak has that book on
thumos and retrieving political emotion
you know but that's that's much later
right
um but this Matrix of like awareness
that's growing that wow there's a lot of
stuff here in Aristotle that's often
under determined and has to be like
thought through and worked out but that
um you know the
practical rationality is going to be
informed by our emotional side rather
than just sort of dominating it which a
more intellectual a top-down kind of
yeah yeah
think anyone was thinking really in
feminist terms then frankly
um I'm trying to think
um I've just lost her name there was a a
person who had uh critique she's no
longer with a political officer who had
critiqued your roles for for making the
um original position opaque to the need
to the family
um it was an influential book at the
time
um but I don't think some of the folks
were really thinking that it was just in
the air I mean yeah yeah after all
um a leading
um intellectual
um you know whose work I think was
respected at the time was
um Carol Gilligan
um you know she she chatted here and
there with folks I definitely had
conversations with her
um but I wasn't really
you know that interested in it I wasn't
bitten by simply the question of of
intentionality although I think the
first paper I ever published was on that
it was on the pro-hyrus's Aristotle's
theory of her hirosis which went into
gory detail
of all the stages of deliberative reason
and the Practical soldiers and practical
syllogisms we're in you know yeah yeah
you know in part because of Donald
Davidson
because he was thinking about
um what you know what what counts as uh
uh in an intention and so
you know
um I think that's part of it
um Von Wright also was writing about
intentionality at the time
so I don't know you know the one article
I do know of it was more feminist and
mine was an early one I think I'm almost
sure I I've published it in the um
essays on Aristotle's ethics critical
essays on Aristotle's ethics and that's
Marshall homiex on practic on on
phrenesis and practical wisdom and how
um it's the best part of the psyche but
women really can't have it or you know
it's
undevelopedics yeah so I that part I do
remember yeah
um you know I was thinking I don't
remember what she wrote her thesis on by
the way so she she taught for years at
Occidental
um uh I think it was I'm pretty sure it
was Occidental
yeah so this is going to sound like a
far out analogy
um
but so you know you've got these the
these women Scholars who are uh engaging
in at the time it's not a complete old
boys club there's there's openings but
it is you know an environment where
um you're held up to probably more
scrutiny than the average male graduate
student and you you also have this you
know developing
um Community that's that the Aristotle
scholarship and I think ancient
scholarship in general that's getting
more and more attentive to our you know
our desirous emotional side uh trying to
give that it's due and and you're and
you're right it's it's not happening
because people are like well we got to
bring women's perspectives into
Aristotle right so in the field of music
and heavy metal in the the early or late
1970s early in the 1980s there's this
thing called a new wave of British heavy
metal
and there was a band called girl school
and they were an all-woman band
um and they
um you know got brought up quite a quite
a few times are you feminists are you
you know what sort of things are you
running into and they're like no we're
just here to play you know uh we do have
to put up with some BS from time to time
but we you know it's not like we
deliberately only learned from the
female bands before us you know we're
hanging out with Motorhead uh Lemmy was
a big promoter of them and uh they
actually did some collaborations between
Motorhead and and girls school and they
were just out there just kind of
pounding away you know just just like um
doing their thing and yet they opened
the door to all in a way they did the I
I may get in trouble for saying this uh
because it's kind of a silly assertion
but in a way they were more feminists
than a band that would go out there and
say
um we're deliberately doing these
practices to break in here they just
played really good rock and roll role
showed up when they were supposed to put
up with the crap that you you kind of
have to do just in the profession in
general and never gave up you know so
they became really top-notch
practitioners
um in within the field without having to
ever stake a stand you know with
Aristotle right so there's all this
misogyny within Aristotle himself right
um and you gotta you know you gotta
that's a topic perhaps we'll talk about
as well what do you do with that right
one one option is just to say well he's
mistaken about that you know like like I
was just reading McIntyre's plain
persons and moral theory the other day
because I teach it in class and he was
saying you know Aristotle says terrible
things about Ordinary People but he
doesn't have any good Arguments for that
so we could just set it aside
it's always hard to know what to do yeah
yeah but I mean if you're in a milieu
where people have been reading that over
and over and over again
I imagine it's not quite quite so easy
as just to Simply set it aside
um and yet you know we see you know you
brought up some really important names
Martha Nussbaum julianas your own
contributions
um there's there's this like in the the
late 20th century going into the 21st
century just massive contributions
um
by women Scholars to Aristotle also in
stoicism also in platonism you know also
well epicureanism as well
so
um
maybe there doesn't have to be any sort
of deliberately
feminist Motif in order for people to
start picking up on the aspects of
Aristotle that were underplayed
so um interesting points um on the
subject of rock again I'm very much
aside I remember being in Brattleboro
Vermont Once We Were
heading up there for some reason we
stopped at a coffee shop and there was a
band where the is all women and the lead
guitarist was women and I had never seen
that so you know I can't tell you must
have been our Cambridge years because we
were up there then so that's going to be
in the 70s so sort of an interesting
eye-opener for me
um I think you know at the time when I
was working on Aristotle a classmate or
if not in my class per se but around the
time was a woman named Sybil
schwarzenbach who for a long time taught
it
in the in the City University system
Baroque okay
um and
um she worked on
Civic friendship Aristotle and Civic
friendship and probably had a lot to say
at the time about more directly feminist
issues or issue or how Aristotle treats
treats women but you know without
spearheading women's causes I mean look
Martha was the first woman to be named a
fellow at Harvard the Harvard
um Society of fellows that's
groundbreaking I mean there's no other
way you can put it it's groundbreaking
um
and came out of Classics and philosophy
or um
and
women were getting their phds
um you know and I came from a very
I don't know to call it prestigious I
wasn't thinking of it at the time but it
was a you know it was a college that
celebrated women as professionals Bryn
Mawr and it had a long tradition of
nurturing women in the Prof in the
academic professions
um and so I just sort of assumed
um that you know I'll plow through all
that and I never really yeah I think
Rawls was very generous to his women
students there I mean it's it's been
said it's been written about it yeah who
all his students were there Barbara
Herman Chris Kors guard myself I mean uh
Jeannie Hampton who's no longer with us
oh right sadly
um
you know the the there were Tom Thomas
poga of complicated background these
days
um but and he was the only one at the
time in addition to
um
one other person Cohn who took on air
took on rawls's own work but um Josh
Cohn
um but all of us were doing history and
so history had been reinstated as a
subject you could study and really dig
your teeth into and you would and could
could get the support
um Hillary Putnam was a very supportive
advisor so some of it has to do with
who's supportive in the field yeah yeah
who helped support your careers and I
have to say I I can't say this in
general you know for everyone because as
I said I was on the women's students
Coalition and we saw lots and lots of
inequity around us
um but in a field like philosophy as
opposed to maybe economics yeah um there
was an opportunity for people who
excelled for women who Excel to get um
place you know and that's it so there's
women you might say at the cost of many
other groups who were squeezed out
you know forget affirmative action
issues but I mean yeah yeah many people
it wasn't necessarily Equitable but that
was considered what was
um a way of leveling the field at the
time or not that's a bad phrase but you
know what I mean a way of letting people
and who might otherwise not be yeah
creating openings or fashion yeah and
and doing so in a sustained way I mean I
I like what you said about
um some of these people who were
teachers and mentors it doesn't take
necessarily doing something in a very
programmatic way bringing it up every
class session just to behave decently to
people and offer them opportunities
um regardless of who they happen to be
you know
I mean in a way that's to make it more
about to make it more meritocratic right
where you can say well if they've got
the talent I'll promote them all Foster
them I'll connect them with these are
small numbers you know I can't say if
you're coming out of a large large large
University and I really can't speak to
what the Dynamics were like in other uh
Universities at that time yeah I'm in a
class of five
Fiverr enter you know five enter that's
what they support with fellowships and
of course you don't go to graduate
school and philosophy unless you're
being paid otherwise you're well I mean
some people too but that is I mean
persons of pedigree with large with you
know with trust funds there's yeah
there's two there's two kinds there's
there's exactly that
um which you know if that becomes the
main amount of people in the field we're
really in trouble and then there's those
who
um
they engage in kind of a risky Venture
you know they they show up to a place
and they hope that the next year they'll
get funding so they take out loans for
the first year and then maybe it happens
or maybe it doesn't you know
um it's it's 35 000 gets expensive each
year yeah I don't envy the the condition
of current graduate students
um and it was you know we're of
different Generations
um I came up in the 90s and it was
starting to get tough and tight then but
it's nothing like what it's like now you
know
there is actually one thing I wanted to
bring up from
um the fabric of character and it's a
term and I wanted to I mean I think it's
a great term ethical salience
ah and I've you know I've used it myself
to try to describe you know sometimes
you
there's there's an experience or a
reality or something but we don't have
the right name for it and somebody comes
along like yourself in that book and
then says well here's here's what we're
going to call it it's not the perfect
name but it's good enough for right now
and it seems to make
um sense out of a lot of matters you
know it's what we what we're in a
situation
we bring you know Concepts and we bring
our our desires and affectivity but we
still have to like see and this is where
you know the typical virtue ethics we
have to see what's ethically Salient in
a situation and one of the cases that
you make is well the development of
character is in part figuring out how to
do that well
um so you and I could be in the same
situation and and maybe you see things
that I don't see or I do see but I don't
prioritize them the way that you do and
you come up with the the right approach
and I come up with not the wrong
approach but a less effective or less on
point approach because I don't grasp
that so I was wondering um how did you
how do where did that term come from to
begin with good question so I think
there was an article or a chapter of a
book and if I could sort of pull it out
in a moment maybe it's a nostal's
fragility of goodness but I'm not sure
discern the Discerning the particulars
but that okay yeah yeah Aristotle yeah
book two
where he says essentially in the
Judgment or the hay crisis rests in
istasis and perception
and so meaning you've got to be able to
size things up
and uh
the I'm not sure if she uses the word
salience I have a feeling it was
probably used by her Pro you know
um but because hard to know what other
word to use right it's yeah moral
salience became a thing
um even for those that weren't
necessarily
thinking about Aristotle right
um and some people use the phrase
cottoning on you know like um ah I get
it that's a little more of it can
shinian yeah yeah quite vegan
the aha moment where you know how to go
on whatever the Meaning go on means
yeah
so I it has to do with the you know and
then particularism came into fashion
um as a non-historical subject
um John
um Jonathan Dancy and others started
thinking a lot about particularism in
part through the phrase again the idea
of salience but
um
you know kind of legal perception I
spent a fair bit of time at some some
point I can't remember what article or
when thinking about Equity
um okay look five because that's the
same similar kind of judgment right
right it's not it's spirit and not
letter of the law and
there was a um uh an idea of
um
of kind of
assessing things
um
in a non-rule-oriented way so the idea
of top-down rule hempelian kind of
generalized rule here's a case and This
falls out under it yeah that was aerosol
says you know things hold epitaphalu
only for the most part right right yeah
so that blended with that idea and there
was definitely a move at the time
to think about a Kant and and Aristotle
for sure as not being rule theorists you
know they were not
um
HRM hair kind of rules right that that
stuff wasn't a way to think about
Aristotle so the more that he could put
into perception the better you know
leaves you kind of dangling as to how
you understand it but certainly it
occurred to me that emotional
sensitivity was a critical part of
perceiving and yeah you became very
merged and they were lower down in the
in the food chain you might say then all
this heavy duty practical deliberation
but it would be the way that you could
understand
the minor premise of the syllogism
because how would you know that
um and this is the right moment for that
right yeah this is such an occasion
you wouldn't really know because there's
a 25 different ways you could avoid it
oh no it's not a cancer stick it's just
a delicious after dinner treat
so it also got into the weakness of will
conversation right yeah acrosia
um yeah
so shifting topics
um a bit you've done a lot of work on
not just military ethics but also we
could say the psychology of military
life and the dangers that it presents
and you've not just done this in a
purely academic way you've you've taught
courses
um you've engaged in conversations and
and workshops and things like that as
well
what was the impetus for for that
because it's kind of an unusual it's
definitely a second career track right
yeah and a sharp a sharp turn
um I got a phone call in the mid 90s or
maybe
93 4. I don't remember the exact date or
year
um from the Naval Academy uh I live in
the greater DC area and so Annapolis
where the naval United States Naval
Academy isn't that far yeah they were
embroiled in a cheating scandal oh which
was called The Double E Electrical
Engineering cheating scandal
and 136 Smith shipment if I have that
right or
165 I I can't remember exactly but it
was in the hundreds maybe 150-ish uh
were implicated and they were
youngsters that's a phrase for um
sophomores they're finishing their
sophomore year okay in the in one of the
middle uh December of their sophomore
year in the military at all these
academies Air Force West Point
um which is Army and Navy
you have uh they're government funded
and you're
um
first you can quit your first two years
without paying back anything okay but
once you hit your third year if you quit
you owe
and so this became high stakes for a lot
of people and it fell under you know all
the agencies uh and and the cabinet
posts have
um
um invest
um ig's inspector generals and it was
under it already elevated to the
Inspector General
um it was also the time of tail hook
uh which was a horrible treatment of
women at um a Naval aviator conventions
a gauntlet and all that so I was brought
in as someone who had taught uh ethics
for a long time
and they just sort of said could you
help brainstorm with us okay we're in
the middle of this Scandal they didn't
use the word yeah
that's what it was it was well also you
know it's they're under the view of of
DC West Point's pretty crowd yeah but
Annapolis is right here close to
Washington so they asked if I could just
think up help them over the summer with
a Remy they called it moral remediation
and Remediation course for the 133
midship and I thought that was
who have been have been suspected of
compromising an exam
so and that meant actually getting into
a professor's office at the time and and
there's a phrase that goes around which
in the military which is essentially
good um cheating material you know and
it was too good to be true
um meaning it was the exam yeah so
it led my to my very quickly
um standing up again a phrase they use a
course for the summer that had a
standard teaching of Ethics as well as
um counseling and in town
work community service okay it was very
comprehensive and some of those
individuals did end up
um
having being represented by Council it
was very very messy
um and it led to heads rolling including
the superintendent I Not only was
brought on for the summer I ended up
being asked would you like to we're
going to fund this position called the
distinguished chair in ethics we'd like
you to be the inaugural holder can you
yeah we're gonna name it
the stock I think it even became named
the Stockdale you know because of
Admiral Stockdale who was a very
celebrated
um Naval graduate who was the longest
serving pow and the senior pow alongside
John McCain so all of that led to three
years of my life okay where I was
teaching there and my um closest
colleagues roughly my age at the time
were guys that had fought in Vietnam
they knew the Mekong Delta they were
Marine Colonels now like retired Marine
Colonels they were they were Admirals
for Star Admirals retired who had flown
many many missions
um
they were pows former pows
um it was intense but I
that was before we were in the forever
Wars right colleagues who had fought in
Vietnam were one generation and the
younger were just returning
from being aviators over a place called
The Basra road that was the first Gulf
War right
and in the early 90s and they had just
landed jobs at the Naval Academy out of
battle
and then I went back to Georgetown after
three years and I thought well you know
while they're I actually was thinking a
lot about those days and I thought they
think stoicism is suck it up and truck
on right that has got to be wrong and it
led me to go back to thinking about the
blessings and curses of stoicism and
why why and how they read Epictetus
wrong I mean Stockdale had survived
because of Epictetus really but he was
you know reading it slenderly you might
say and he really memorized it and I had
interviewed him a few times in writing
that book so I knew and I was you know
and I was brought out to San Diego a bit
to
um give talks in his honor you know so I
have a very close connection with him
and
with stoicism as a part of the military
culture what happened then as I went
back to Georgetown and come 9 11 in Post
9 11 I started getting into my
classrooms in a DC uh University people
that had fought and were getting their
first degrees or were getting phds yeah
and that many of them couldn't talk
about their Wars they didn't know how to
process it uh at the time I think many
thought enlisting was the right way to
go if they enlisted
um you know and we're not from an
academy
um
they doubted it afterwards I mean it was
very very complicated yeah moral
scenario to say the least and that is
what led me to think about moral injury
and not just stoic Armament you might or
stoic armor but
um or or a myth of invincibility but you
know right right PTSD that isn't just
um uh hyper vigilance due to
threat of life it was more hyper
vigilance and and unrest due to moral
anguish yeah I mean we encounter a lot
of people more broadly who do have this
mistaken view of stoicism and let's call
it life challenges and emotional
responses that like I said is about
toughening you know keeping all the bad
stuff out uh tamping the emotions down
and and I always point out well how the
hell are you supposed to do that if you
don't actually understand your emotions
and why you feel this way about things
and
um
you know it seems like we're always
fighting an uphill battle against that
with stoicism in particular
um I will say too just as an aside
um stoic Warriors is a book that I've
suggested to many ROTC students at the
various places that I've I've taught
um because they're you know almost
always a Roxy program somewhere you know
and then they get interested in in
stores you know yeah they pick up Marcus
Aurelius or carry it in their rucksack
as they say
yeah I I do think you know this is a bit
off topic and I do want to Circle back
to talking about um stoicism and aerosol
but
um I I think you're right about the
let's call it restrictedness of
stockdale's
interpretation of of stoicism and of
Epictetus and where I saw this coming up
um so I used to teach in a Maximum
Security Prison that was my first
full-time teaching gig Indiana State
Prison in uh Michigan City in Indiana
and stoicism was quite popular among
quite a few of the guys and
um we were using a textbook uh it was
the Summers and I forget what the title
of it was for her stuff yeah but it had
anthologized I have it down there
somewhere yeah yeah it had Stockdale
some Stockdale and then it had some
Epictetus so so we we did it and they
like they they sucked it up and they
were like yeah this is this is great
this gives a survival thing exactly and
and I think you know at some point if I
remember right
Stockdale says Epictetus is and stoicism
is the philosophy for a prison camp
which then raises the question well is
it a is it really a philosophy for
everybody else you know or is it just
for them yeah Tad Brennan asks that you
know it's a philosophy of deprivation
um at least some versions of it but is
it for everyone else I was once
interviewing Stockdale and Coronado and
he was sitting at the dining room table
a humble house and his leg was jutted
out because he had it broken down much
like epic well yeah he identified with
Epictetus in part through that he when
he was pummeled by the Vietcong it led
to a permanently
dysmorphic leg essentially anyway
um his wife Sybil uh in the kitchen at
the time was over here overhearing this
remark that he made
um
I would return I would go back to you
know prison just for the just for
Epictetus again or you know or it was it
was not just a philosophy that stayed in
my life it's a it is the philosophy and
it was
it wasn't quite the silver lining of
being in prison but it was it is what
gave meaning to his life thereafter and
he would do it it's interesting he would
do it again and she marched in with no
no uncertain terms and said well I would
choose a different philosophy
and she was a trooper because she had
been to DC a lot during his internment
and fought hard with many other of the
they were only wives at the time
with McNamara at the time to get
the folks out of the Hanoi Hilton so you
know she was not a lightweight yeah
again that brings something to mind from
the prison experience
um
sometimes there were guys within the
prison who would say you know I hate
being here
and I I'm looking forward to getting out
but I really really needed to come here
and it was because they recognized I
mean that moral Reformation really does
take place it doesn't usually take place
through the programs that the state you
know provides or the volunteers coming
in it's much more individualized and
it's what happens on the cell blocks
among the the prisoners rather than like
just the the volunteers but you know
they would they would take the things
that we're studying in philosophy and
really use them to develop a new
self-understanding which included like
wow was I screwed up you know I I was
fortunately I came here rather than
getting getting myself killed or
damaging more people or stuff like that
and then that was part of their
transition to whenever the state was
going to let them out being ready to to
go out and uh you know as we say become
productive members of society which
means you know being able to be a decent
human being and not make the same
mistakes
um
yeah there was something else I was
going to ask you about
um
so you you do have a new book project
going on and you said that before we get
started it's kind of there's a return to
Aristotle I mean it's not as if you ever
left him behind
um but you have been doing a lot more
stoic-oriented stuff yeah so what's
what's the new project yeah yeah
so um
it occurred to me in part in doing
more stoic stuff
uh then I still gets sidelined a lot you
know he's obviously harder to understand
it doesn't toss out
pithyaphorisms you know that can be
sprinkled online
[Laughter]
some of the ones that are out there are
fake
that's true too but some sell a lot of
money yeah
um but he
as I teach
courses you know Tech seminars at
Georgetown for your undergraduates or
graduate courses in ancient philosophy
going back to Aristotle is so rich
I don't find
that rich they're much more organized of
course they are and you know in their
nomenclature and their taxonomies and
inventiveness with words certainly yeah
stipulations is or are are neater but
Aristotle really is a you know he he's
curious he's inquisitive and his he's a
Titan you know he he moves from
breathing and dreaming to stars to parts
of animals to Crustaceans to you know
spiny and grisly bones I mean everything
at all is a part of the wonders of we
all desire to know and uh and um and um
evidence of this is the pleasure we take
in or the Delight we take in it as he
opens the metaphysics so I was thinking
of this in connection with a new stage
of life
um that is new compared to Aristotle
Aristotle has been with me longer than
um my closest family member who is my
husband
um and that is grandchildren okay my
grandchildren are very good company
they're young
they're very funny they are extremely
inquisitive
extremely curious and they are great
observers of Nature and they like to
play
and I like to play with them so I've
been thinking a lot about Aristotle in
that connection
it sounds wacky it sounds odd but it's a
very it's taking me down many Avenues so
that's that's the feeler so is is part
of it I mean this is something that
Aristotle doesn't really
explicitly work out but there I think
there's all sorts of hints like thinking
about intergenerational
connections is that right exactly he
talks you know happiness is
flourishing not in a day not a summer
one swallow but a whole lifetime yeah
you know that you know what you do now
may reflect on
I tell my kids what you're doing now may
reflect on my legacy when I'm dead right
[Laughter]
I remember Bernard Williams was telling
us in the lecture it was hysterical he
said you know I do think I think there
is total worry that when he was dead
him and did he you know did he hold up
well
anyway yeah that's sort of I mean he
does have a he does have a good body
though to like preserve his legacy and
theophrastus you know so I mean most
people I don't know that they have if
they do have somebody like that it's
usually a spouse right or it's yeah or
you know Seneca made sure he was writing
pretty well for for future Generations
right I think he just had Aryan or Aryan
found him or you know the transmission
of texts is a complicated matter
but anyway I am you know I I and also
the but getting back to earlier topics
the idea of of
um friendship and
um moral education character growth
through friendship we improve by taking
on the mold of others that we emulate
um all of all of that and all of the
role of of
um of zest and vibrancy that comes with
the immersed engaged life that's social
as well as
Aristotle had to have been immersed in
nature you know he was all right at the
shoreline's collecting Crustaceans and
mollusks so you know and that's sort of
what kids
thrive in so it's a it's a playful book
um but that's what's caught by fancy
that sounds like a really interesting
project and I'm looking forward to to
seeing it when it when it comes out and
reading it
um
I was kind of wondering since we've
brought up you know stoicism Aristotle
um this is something that I've talked
about with Massimo quite a bit who now
identifies as I do as a ciceronian
eclectic meaning somebody who you know
likes difference
um Traditions schools is willing to try
to blend them together at points and at
certain points say well no they're not
compatible here and here we got to pick
one or the other Piggly yeah yeah and
and my it's it's also a stance that I
I take as well and I was wondering if I
mean how do you so you've done a lot of
work on aerosol a lot of work on
um the stoics all you know a lot of work
on a lot of other people as well
including Khan
um one of the challenges I think that
you know that
viewers uh who are like starting out
studying philosophy might benefit from
is hearing how how you How do you keep
these things all up in your head
it'll go to you know
well is it like that is it like a crowd
of them just shouting you know different
things that sometimes contradict each
other or do you do you force them into
like collaborating with each other or I
mean these are kind of silly
um
well the quest question really came
thundering
you know to me in a thundering way when
I was working in Aristotle and Khan okay
there were two voices there and I
couldn't let go of them and they were
talking very loudly and in part it had
to do with two advisors I have who were
both are they both talking in ways that
are very persuasive to you at the time
well
um yeah just undergrad really
um you know you can't work on I don't
think you can work on a a historical
figure
um and and as a scholar without really
taking them seriously and thinking they
are worth your time otherwise it's not
worth spending time on it you know I
could yeah maybe find some that I I
wouldn't spend time in but you know they
have to they have to be appealing to you
in some way or really have interesting
things to say or have come alive to you
through the secondary literature and and
that definitely was yeah yeah with
Emmanuel Khan and you know I had studied
um the first critique early on in my
career when I was at Edinburgh under wh
Walsh Richard Walsh and I knew that I
really was moved by him but it was the
um it was under roles that um the moral
philosophy really just was amazing and
then I did a lot of work on the
anthropology emotions so he had a lot
more to say about things that no one was
talking about so there is this whole
thing and there is a little person has a
lot to say about emotions but they're
not really in the nick of McKee in
ethics they're right rhetoric or the
poetic or you know to the left and to
the right yeah and so in a certain way
even within an author you're you're
you're
um
you're uh filling out the picture by
seeing what texts
um have been ignored or need to be
thought through again so it you know
it's not a slam dunk I'll just go to
this this chapter where everyone's
quoting it really is an immersion so for
for me it's very much you know something
catches my attention and then it's an
immersion and a lot of the immersion is
very messy it it there's a lot of
notebooks you know in the day when I'm
only using writing by hand or script
there's a lot of pages or on a computer
um notes they're I'm a I'm a book user I
really find it easier to have printed
stuff and yeah stickems everywhere
Post-its everywhere so oh and you know
books take a very long time to write at
least the books I write they seem to
take a very long time to get it right so
it's an immersion I wouldn't you know
that it's not like one voice screams out
loud or I sometimes when I
I'm thinking like when I was reading
um content in the anthropology or
religion within the limits of reason
alone had so many interesting things to
say in in the religion about community
and yeah launching under a banner of
community
um a banner virtue and I thought boy
that you don't see that in the
groundwork so you have to kind of
resuscitate but make a strong case for a
minority view on occasion I guess that's
what
um you know what
um lawyers do as well and that kind of
text I've always enjoyed that textual
um investigation it's very hard I think
and this is a a task I
um feel very committed to it's hard for
young graduate students to take it to
take it on I really don't believe we're
just talking to um fellow Scholars you
know that are that spend 24 hours a day
in the library yeah have that kind of
access
um you know that is the way to get
credentialed I have to say and it is the
way to make it in the thing called The
Academy
um
but it isn't much of a help you know if
you've got a spouse or family members
that are very bright but are not in your
profession there's no way they can
understand what you're talking about
when you start talking about the you
know the minor premise of the Practical
syllogism in demoto Animalia yeah yeah
it just doesn't wash yeah and so I've
learned how to you know sometimes at my
Peril and sometimes
um in a way that I feel is important to
to be public facing you do it as well
and that's a commitment it does mean
it's like a it's a two-step dance it
means you have to do all the work that
you would do
for writing a book to be read by 10.
yeah yeah and then all the work you'd
have to do to make it readable
and you know in somewhat accessible with
with without cutting corners and that's
yeah that's a difficult thing to it's a
balance you know there'll be some that
love you for it and others that hate you
for it
can't win all you know can't wait
going back to like
um graduate students one of the things
that
you know I I think back to my own time
and then
um graduate students that I've
interacted with and met and very often
you know if they're lucky they run into
the kind of
um
teachers mentors that that you had that
can help them out and and a lot of them
get these messages you know it's
interesting to listen to hear them talk
like you know I go to a conference and
you just like stay silent and listen to
them and they're all like well this is
what everybody's doing today you know
and you're like no it's not you know and
but they're they're you know they're all
kind of jockeying with each other and
you get the feeling that many of them
are like just trying to figure out their
way and they get a lot of contradictory
information about what they should be
reading or who's important but you know
you were mentioning so you know like the
con stuff is a great example very few
people read the anthropology from a
pragmatic point of view but there's
really interesting stuff in there I mean
nowadays when they do it it's mainly
because we want to find out how Kant is
racist but there's all this cool stuff
or the um you know religion within the
limits of reason alone which is
essentially a book of Ethics you know
and I I kind of think
you can't really have kant's full moral
philosophy with the groundwork and the
metaphysics of morals and the second
critique without that
um religion within the limits of reason
alone being added to it it's like a key
part of the the picture but you know so
often um they're not getting that
they're you know the The Graduate
students and this I think goes even more
for like the people out there who just
they're you know they're not in
academics but they want to study
philosophy they they are um he was a
McIntyre and term resourceless in the
sense that they don't know
where to start or what to read you know
I see this all the time with so I've got
this huge half hour Hegel project that
I've been doing for nine years there's
over 350 videos and it's on the
phenomenology and I it's kind of a
kixotic project that I probably wouldn't
if I'd known what I was getting into I
wouldn't have actually taken it on but a
lot of people benefit from it
and they're you know because people want
to read the phenomenology because they
think it's important
um but you know I don't want to like
dissuade them and say it's actually not
that important hegel's wrong about so
many different things you know but I do
tell them you know if you if you want to
study Hegel the phenomenology sure as
hell isn't the place to start you know
pick an easier work like the lectures on
the philosophy of History right history
yeah well I always say lectures on the
philosophy of History plus it's the
lectures on the history of philosophy
because then you've got like some at
least you know who Plato is and when he
talks about it you get his his shtick
but there's you know there's all these
people out there that have I don't know
they've been sold a line in one way or
another if you're going to study this oh
with Aristotle 2 I see this all the time
people are like well I gotta begin with
the organon before I go to the nick of
McCain ethics and I'm like no you don't
uh you can you can read the nick of
McCain ethics just just fine added solid
you know
um you're not going to be applying that
stuff from posterior your analytics to
the nick of McCann ethics anyway because
when you do you're going to generate uh
crazy stuff you know like what you see
Thomas doing in his commentary you know
where everything has to be in a
syllogism when it's not you know anyway
because the topics is I mean doing it
topically rather than I never have done
a philosophy of History
um only from you know A to Z but it
doesn't work well here so here's here's
the the I'll bring this to an actual
question yeah please so for for people
out there whether they're in academics
or whether they're just interested in
engaging in study of philosophy what
advice would you have with them about
this
um people telling them well this is the
way you have to do it you know
good question well I don't really know
what the way you have to do it is
or who's whispering in their ear you
know their and what's fashionable today
is
um you know is no longer fashionable
um tomorrow or was fashionable yesterday
yeah
so
I often
you know I take out a ton of books from
the library or you know I buy them used
and so you have a lot of used ones on
your shelf and if someone's mentioned
something or other and you know and I I
start reading it yeah turns out to be
interesting like I'm reading the history
of animals now on Aristotle it's really
it's it's very interesting I'm not
reading it because oh it doesn't follow
the posterior analytics and yeah yeah
and is he really thinking about
teleology when he's doing all this
observational
tons of things what is that about he's
not following his own dictum
I'm reading it I am reading it hungrily
because I'm interested in him as a
curious mind as an observer but I'm I'm
reading it because I find it interesting
and I'll probably even read on dreaming
because I find it interesting and it's
awesome those serendipitous dips into
uh if it's history we've been talking
only really about history philosophy
into texts that get you
fascinated or hooked I did read the
phenomenology that was my first
historical dip as a oh really I have
more in a college I had my professors
um George Klein was my mentor and tutor
and
um and I read that and then I actually
went for a year to be you because John
Finley was there and I that was the only
place where I could study Hegel and oh
go to BU I I couldn't stand be you it
was the days of silver and I ended up in
Edinburgh but I ended up in Edinburgh
and I worked I had worked on cot before
and so I returned to that
um with someone Richard Walsh who was
w.h Walsh who was actually a hegelian so
some of these things we go for are very
um hard and you know you don't really
get it until much later but you know if
they don't float your boat then leave it
you know if John Locke doesn't float
your boat you know tried yeah yeah try
Mill you know
Etc or it doesn't have to be history I
don't really know about the Fab things
or what you have to do there's too much
of that oh yeah nobody can stay on top
of it now you know yeah and those and
media social media has just corrupted
the whole planet so
yeah I mean the social media thing has
invested texts like the phenomenology of
spirit and espinoza's ethics too as well
with what I call auras where people
you know they talk about it this will
this will be the text that'll like
figure out everything for you and every
you know all your questions will fall in
place and of course that's not the case
nobody who's actually read the stuff
would would say that but it gets um
circulated around and people will
um
get into long long conversations about
that
where they're using Snippets from these
texts you know some of these poor
scholarships no matter what so if you
think in a certain way you know but you
were asking me earlier just to Circle
back for example about moral salience in
many ways yeah John McDowell you know
contributed to that conversation in no
small way okay
and but he was trained in ancient very
very deeply so in ancient in Britain and
he
um you know understood the idea of
of um
seeing something in it silencing that
was his phrase it silences other reasons
it's not a you know a gladiator fight it
just the way oh yeah a virtue style of
it you Cotton On I used that earlier and
you yeah silence other
um other um other points of view and
that's sort of what virtue is it's not
um a battle of the strongest there just
isn't another voice so it might be say
that's what Temperance is not not
content I mean we have we have a classic
precedent for that the end of The Credo
you know where Socrates is saying ah you
know whatever arguments you've got these
arguments over here are buzzing too
loudly for me to hear them
that's true so the other thought is to
with I've often I'm just a great reader
fiction and um you know and I learned
some of the most important things from
fiction and some of the great writers
are so
erudite I mean they are steeped and
stuff and yeah hear their philosophy
coming out or they can distill it in
certain ways I'm a great lover of them
or tolls and recently read gentlemen in
Moscow and I I just was bowled over by
his understanding of so many spheres of
thought
um you know including Marxism in a
certain way
um and I think you learn a lot from not
in philosophical texts if you're a
philosopher yeah you can bring them to
bear and so those are often
if not the lightness in your step that
can can come from you know relieving
yourself of some of the plotting nature
of philosophical reading yeah yeah it's
also just some of the
um insight
George Elliott is it is a great
philosophical writer
um very much a philosopher of sorts
um a little plotting at times but you
know
so I want to ask you about that but I
also want to throw out an anecdote that
I'm sure you've probably heard before
um G Moore really like to read novels
and apparently according to him he
didn't make as much progress in
philosophical work because it was like
it wasn't just a guilty pleasure it was
he would read novels instead of reading
philosophy because he preferred to read
novels I've never heard that I never
heard that
I mean to me that doesn't seem like such
a bad thing you know is this a hand is
this a hand yeah yeah
um but I was going to ask so you
mentioned just a few people already are
who are your go-to authors in the sense
of like they stick with you and you're
gonna go back to them over and over
again in different like different years
and keep on enjoying them and keep
finding that uh
that depth in their work
imagine Georgia
um literary right yeah well I I suppose
they could be yeah sure happy to
contribute
um I recently discovered
Shirley Hazard
h-a-z-z-a-r-d American Australian
um Transit of Venus I think it's called
I was reading something in the Atlantic
um a review of a biography of about her
and I had never read her and I think I
have that title right I should just
confirm that
um and
I thought
um this is one of the most amazing
novelists whom I never had read before
um Transit of Venus and it's sort of
between I think it's between the wars
um and I just think it
on so many levels it's simply brilliant
so that's that's one not read by many
um I just love amortol
um Amor t-o-w-l-e-s on our tools
um but and I'm
respect I'm liking more than the Lincoln
Highway and um
and I think probably Rules of Civility a
gentleman in Moscow maybe it's in part
it has a lot of relevance right now but
it was written 10 years ago or so I
think he's just
so insightful he character development
you hold on to the character I don't
know if I can go back reading it because
it's very plot driven okay so I know the
plot
um Faulkner is someone I really like but
it's a lot of hard work I you know how
many times I've read the sound of Jerry
I still can't get through the first
sentences you know so the sentence
structure I used to think I liked Henry
James and then I just gave up on wings
so that um I said this is far too hard
work on
my life is too short
um so I think it's way too SUNY I'm a
big fan of Summer Virginia Woolf okay
for all sorts of reasons
um you know and some of it is not great
but some of it is really I like between
the acts a lot um you know I just it
you gotta imagine what it would have
been like then in that period of time so
it's those people walking around
Bloomsbury so it fascinates me
um yeah
[Music]
um
I'm always looking for good novels I'm
not a mystery reader really I'm not a
detective reader detective novel reader
I sort of if I read something I really
want it to be really good litter good
um prose that sort of draws you in
because of the style because of writing
and part okay as well as you know all
the other things that go into making it
up I like George Eliot I'm not sure how
much of it I can go back to regularly
okay I've got these stuff
um it's hard to say what I would return
to and not you know we're cleaning out
our bookshelves because we're they're
just books everywhere crawling out of
every crevice and I'm trying to think
what you know what should I give up and
what to hold on to the truth is I most
of the books that I have from 1969
forgive me for saying they smell moldy
the pages fall out and there's no point
in holding on to them if you can read
them on your Kindle where you're not
going to get them allergies
do you
um also hold on to academic books
um that you've gathered here and there
saying you know I'm going to do work on
this eventually not right now but I
better hold on to this uh you know just
for the project because I found myself
divesting myself of of some of those
that I've carried around for 20 years
and and I'm really looking at my
bookshelf is that why you're saying well
I'm just thinking about my own
experience you know when when Andy and I
moved here to Milwaukee uh now you know
two academics right we had 99 bankers
boxes full of books
and we got rid of a lot of those by
taking them to use bookstores and you
know you can you can sell them off
um and we didn't want to when we moved
we just kind of packed everything up we
left New York came back here to
Milwaukee and we were like we'll sort it
out once we get here and we just had
like boxes of books just piled up all
over the place and we still have too
many books we still have books in some
of those boxes in the closet and I'm I'm
part of the problem because you know
going all the way back to graduate
school if if I thought I might work on
something at some point if I saw a book
that was in a used bookstore that was
germane to it well I'd buy it and then
just say hey well I'll get to this later
you know and sometimes I would and in
probably I would estimate like 90 of the
cases I haven't you know my my
intellectual eyes were bigger than my
intellectual stomach
um so I'm curious if if that's some of
the books that you're now divesting
yourself of is is that the case with you
or is that more you know a me
is it a vice
you know here's this is just a small
smattering you can't quite see the
camera doesn't on the corner but there's
a whole row a whole bookshelf row yeah
not the one that you can see straight
ahead but there's a whole yeah yeah
round of of custom bookshelves there and
then another thing over there those are
the ones I've kept at home and they you
know and I sometimes uh try to rotate
them if as projects come up that I'm
working on so there are things relevant
so I can pull things
um but I have a whole office that is
that duplicates it by maybe twice and
I'm not alone at Georgetown we have
floor-to-ceiling bookshelves yeah
there's
when faculty retire there's no one wants
these books I once thought I would give
all my books to Bryn Mawr they don't
want them yeah we were told books are
cheap they don't want books yeah and the
libraries don't buy books anymore
um Georgetown doesn't buy books so
I this is a problem the whole some
someone leaves their office and the
hallway
becomes filled with bookshelves that
were previously in an office and they
are grazing grounds for people like and
me who at one point think oh I might
work on that I'll take those home and
then
and it was a day when they went to eBay
you know or something like that but that
was a use of resources that what who
hires a separate administrative
assistant in your department simply to
get rid of the books that a faculty
member left behind yeah well ten
thousand of them but I have a funny
story on this and okay it was not last
year but the year before or very close
it was about 15 months ago I was on a
I meet with a group and it includes
Michael waltzer and Michael was moving
from
I don't know how many he was at Harvard
when I was there so you know almost 40
Years of at Princeton to a smaller
apartment in New York City
he was giving up the Princeton residence
and his office at The Institute for
advanced studies
he had he has a mathematical grandson
who had figured out how many books he
had on his wall and what his new
apartment could accommodate and if I
said it was something like a thousandth
it was something to that effect and Judy
waltzer didn't hesitate to say and by
the way I think we have 25 copies in
Japanese of just an unjust War anyone
here reach Japanese
so it is a problem many in academic
faces oh yeah
it was a funny moment
um when he told us the yardage he had to
and he's not you know and he he's a book
guy you know at his age he's a book guy
he's not he's not reading stuff only
online
this is funny I mean that is a uh I
don't want to go too far along with this
because I don't want to be respectful of
your time but I mean that is an issue
with libraries right they're they're
constantly throwing things out
and I I used to get a lot of good books
that way and the discard piles
um and you know and many of them are
books that just haven't been checked out
since forever
um but it's it's unfortunate because we
lose access to so much stuff that way
I know for myself when I would do
research I would go to the stacks and
I'd kind of like poke around and the
book that I wanted would be here and
then there'd be another book next to it
that the title looked interesting I take
it down and look through it and then
oftentimes find stuff that was quite yes
it's to the left to the right yeah yeah
but I I think the way of doing research
I just have to say you know I think a
lot of the the students in the present
they they don't do that anymore so they
don't have that experience you know they
a lot of things are online for them so
they they make use of that
but you can't um
you know like you know Hume talks about
you know I you know resemblance and
cause and effect but contiguity is so
important you know
so very true yeah there's not a lot of
contiguity in the PDFs or it's not
physical it's just also you're getting
to a tactile right
um sensibility and way of taking in
knowledge that's very different when our
primary experience is visual
um as opposed to holding the page you
know remembering what that page looked
like right part through
multi-sensorial access and you know
there is a disadvantage and we'll get
off this topic but you know that is I
can't always find the books on my shelf
because they're not accessible through a
search engine yeah I have
um three copies of Saint Anselm's
prayers and meditations all of which
have underlining and notation in them
um all because I would use it and then
mislay it and then I would search for it
everywhere and then finally Andy would
be like let's we'll just order another
copy you know you need it you can't find
it and then of course immediately after
the new copy comes you find the old copy
great great
well is there anything else that you
wanted to to bring up or talk about
you've been very good I think I think
just one final thing and that is I
mentioned Aristotle I mentioned
grandchildren but part of the theme is
is play oh
um you know
um not something he uh
or most of the Ancients think about in
um positive terms it's Recreation yeah
it's a way to recharge your batteries
um but
or it's trivial it's child stuff and
um
Plato says need for the need for novelty
of the shiny new toy
um but I think play is really important
um and in part
um we've had very hard years
um political uh
pandemic wise
politically
um
climatically
environmental disasters
um it a war in Ukraine that's not
um ending soon
um and that threatens the world these
are tough times they're tough times
should be a philosopher they're tough
times to be
um thoughtful they're tough times to
think about the future
um
they're really really serious problems
that are upon us
um and so
I've just found that we need some
lightness of Step
um some levity and
um some humor
and uh
a playful spirit that isn't often
celebrated
in philosophy of course humor is talked
about sometimes Ted Kona very very
wonderful book on jokes
um
and some people do write about comedy
but you know but those are different
play is a different you know play is a
larger category than right right
and
um I I think we need some respite
um and I'm I'm certainly ready I've
written many heavy books the last three
or four have been extremely heavy about
yeah the inner inner war of war the the
after war of War
um and
um you know suicide epidemics in the
military and elsewhere
um so anyway that's that's the plug it's
it's a slow burning process but it's
it's captivated me and I'm you know I'm
hoping it captivates others
um because we all could use a little um
uplift some surgency in our life yeah
and making a I think making a case for
that in the way that you're talking
about
I can't recall anybody doing that since
uh huizinga you know way better yes
that's a very good memory home I just
read the book from cover to cover and he
wrote that book in 19 in the 1930s or
1920s translated in 50 into his Dutch
into
um um English and it's a it's a it's a
dated book but to say the least but uh
how could it not be I mean given how
much our culture is transformed right
and then he's a he's a um an
anthropologist yeah yeah and a linguist
and all that um but um he you know he
makes some very good points and um
playing is some really important so yeah
but yeah important well that's a great
place to close
um thanks so much for for coming on I've
been looking forward to this
conversation for a very long time it was
a delight Greg really a delight yeah so
um where is the best place for people to
find you and your works is it your
Georgetown
faculty
um
nancysherman.com
www.nancy sherman.com that's a little
better than some Georgetown thing which
I don't often
um update um okay not that I'm the best
at updating things but you can get a
sense but the you know the books are um
widely available and out there and um
we'll put links to all of them Below in
the video description so thank you I
really appreciate that yeah well so a
great conversation thanks so much for
for being here thank you so much Greg be
well and until next time
we'll play next time right